some World Cups in full-swing which of
course means you have to have your
essentials when watching the big games
I've got mine I've got my Funyuns I got
my MD I like to call the doctor and of
course I got a big old TV go TV shopping
today and you're likely to encounter two
very high P new things curve displays
and 4k or ultra high-definition
resolution this $3,300 TV from Samsung
has both so let's start with the curve
as you can see here this display has a
slight bend to it why Samsung and other
TV makers will tell you it's all about
viewing angles and creating an immersive
experience and 3d effects but mostly
it's bunk in fact a curved display in
some cases can actually distort an image
but why should that get in the way of
the TV industry's marketing efforts the
other big feature this TV has is a 4k
resolution which means it has twice as
many pixels as the best TVs out there
increased pixel count should mean better
image quality and way up close it really
does but as you start to move several
feet away the pixel count starts to
matter less and less and then not at all
then there's the question of 4k content
right now there just isn't that much of
it this TV actually comes with a
harddrive preloaded with five movies and
three documentaries now you can't update
this hard drive so I really hope you
liked watching gee I joke x-men origins
a Night at the Museum and the counselor
now there is some 4k content available
on Netflix but right now that's
restricted to Breaking Bad season 2 of
house of cards and Smurfs 2 but not
Smurfs 1 so what's going on here the TV
industry desperately wants you to buy a
new television problem is most of us
bought a new TV in the past few years
already so the industry needs to come up
with new reasons for us to trade in our
old sets for fresh ones first they tried
1080p
increased resolution standard and that
actually kind of worked but then they
tried to push refresh rates on us which
nobody understood and right after that
3d which was a tremendous flop Ultra
High Definition and curve displays are
just the next attempt to make us think
the TV's we own are obsolete which is
pretty hard since the TV's we have are
pretty great already and what really
matters is what's on this is my favorite
program